okay so She-Hulk episode 6 is now out
and we are officially in the last third
of the season the entry is filled with
Easter eggs hidden details and a lot of
callbacks to the comics that we're going
to be breaking down in this video now
last weekend I did with two big teases
the first of which was that Jen was
given an extra costume and the second
was that Daredevil was gonna be coming
to the show Jen also defeated titanium
in a legal battle and we once more saw
an appearance by Todd who I'll talk more
about later on in the video as you
already know Daredevil isn't in the
episode and after last week's tease it's
another Ralph boner that makes my Ralph
boner go down I was even hoping that
we'd get a book of Boba Fett situation
where we actually had two episodes of
Daredevil Netflix is Daredevil but
because we didn't I've smashed my
[ __ ] TV up canceled my Disney Plus
subscription and I killed Sparky too I
killed him and I'll kill you I'll kill
them all
I'm guessing he's coming next week or
they might just be dangling the carrot
in front of us so we keep watching the
show were you disappointed that's my
first question up top do you care let me
know below and if you enjoy the
breakdown then please Hulk smash that
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for reviews and Recaps on the
series every week by the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
She-Hulk episode six
[Music]
so the episode is titled just Jen
signifying how she's trying to just be
herself we even get this in the title
sequence which has his text instead of
just the typical She-Hulk stuff Series
has taken a much bigger focus on her and
in the comics Jin actually spent 99 of
her time in Hershey Hulk form I'm
guessing the CGI budget had something to
do with that but it also helps to add to
the Dynamics that she's trying to live a
normal life whether she's constantly
pulled back into the superhero side of
things and we see she can't even go to a
wedding without it kicking off we start
off the entry with a strong focus on her
name letting us know that Jen will take
center stage in this episode you might
notice that the Box itself is also
similar to the pink that's synonymous
with Titania who ends up popping up
later in the entry she wears a pink suit
calling back to theirs and she may have
even pulled some strings with this
wonderful invitation box either way it's
a friendly lose wedding day and though
we hear mumblings of her superhero
costume she ends up donning another one
by Luke Jacobs Luke Jacobs is actually a
superhero costume designer from the
comics that I'm guessing we'll be
replacing Melbourne if you cast your
mind back to Daredevil then you might
remember that Melvin was taken into
custody and therefore he's probably not
going to be in the show now it's a shame
that we don't get to see this in this
episode but we know that it will be
popping up at some point in the future
kind of feel like this entry is based
around the movie Bridesmaids and though
we've had strong Ally McBeal influences
without even popping up in the bar in
episode 2 have clearly pulled from other
things might be also based on the movie
My Best Friend's Wedding I don't know I
haven't seen it so [ __ ] off you don't
come to my channel for wedding stuff do
you because I've got no idea on that
anyway Nikki ends up working alongside
Mallory Burke who pretty much provides
the foundation for the B subplot story
now Mallory Burke is an interesting
character due to what happens to her in
the comics she ended up becoming an
enemy of Jen you know her constantly
causing lots of Chaos in her life though
they work together for the Titania case
I can't see the tides turning and she
may end up being a mid-level villain
that reports to the higher-ups known as
the base who never lost a case she ended
up becoming part of a shadowy
organization that tried to create their
own version of She-Hulk Jen brought this
down but it could end up tying in with
the blood plot and those that want to
create their own hooks now shulkey shows
up at the event with all attention
turning her hair due to her being in her
She-Hulk form her mate begs her not to
upstage her at the wedding but this ends
up not being the case we know her name
is Lulu and this might be a not to
Louise Grant aka the blonde Phantom from
the comics she's not really featured
that much in She-Hulk so probably a
reach but the nickname Lulu was also
shared by her so I thought I'd include
that just in case back at the law firm
we actually meet a character from the
comics in Mr Immortal in the source
material Mr Immortal was a character
that discovered he was unable to die
after attempting to end his life several
times initially he wanted to do nothing
more than die but realizing that he
couldn't gave him a new sense of
Vitality this enabled him to do more and
more dangerous things and he slowly grew
Reckless over time living forever he
initially saw nothing but the good side
of life however when those around him
started to pass away he became massively
depressed he's here to do a divorce case
and we learn that he's been married
several times and due to things going
stale he ends up offering himself to get
out of it wish I had a way to get out of
covering the show but moving on I hope
my Disney PR rap isn't watching this
video I don't think he's watching it now
we later meet his several wives and his
husband and a Abomination mate you're
gonna be in big trouble too the guy is
basically a master Fortune over the
decades and stuff like Apple shares from
1981 but he's still gonna be torn a new
one if this settlement goes their way
either way Immortal man is another male
piece of for the show and to get out of
the situation my man jumps out of a
window denim style from the I.T crowd
landing on a security guard's car we get
our QR code for the episode which is a
link to West Coast Avengers 46. in this
Hawkeye discovers that the Avengers name
is being used without permission but
it's mainly notable for the appearance
by a mortal man however it being used
without permission could also link to
Titania who we know from last week was
suing Jen for the trademark now Jenny's
question on her love life and please
please Matt show up next week mate I
know I should be interested in this
wedding stuff but I'm not I'm not I just
I just want my white male superheroes
back I'm such a stereotype
now at this point we see that Titania
has weasled her way into the Wedding by
dating you look at you you're such a
dork see you chump anyway she's starting
to gravitate more towards her comic book
look I think the fact that she's wearing
purple here is to signify that Titania
has had many costumes over the years but
they've all had this purple tint to them
due to it being the character's main
color she has boss earrings and they
also talk about her 50 businesses I feel
like the character in general is a
comment on the Kardashians who of course
all have their clothing and makeup lines
self-made self-made billionaires they
are self-made like Titania and it shows
how Titania's reputation is still strong
even after the several controversies
that have been surrounding her this
entire storyline brought a lot of
flashbacks for me namely the time I
showed up to a wedding and Ryan area was
there as the best man
like mine Jen's pleased to expose the
whole thing falls on deaf ears and she
ends up going outside to do what I did
which says sit alone because I [ __ ]
hate Ryan area hey um shut the [ __ ] up
Ryan Airy oh here we meet Josh's daddy
Paul and unlike the other men he
actually seems like he might be
interested in Jen in the credits we can
see his name is Josh Miller but I don't
know any characters called this so let
me know if you do now back at the office
we get mention of some very important
villains in the intelligent show if you
watch the leaks part of our video last
week then you'll know how he talked
about how Daniel rbk reported that these
would be popping up in the series in the
comics they're basically a super group
of extremely intelligent villains that
are made up of the most monstrous Minds
on the planet this lineup includes
Murdoch and we know he'll be popping up
in Ant-Man quantumania here the name is
used for a website that's said to be for
hateful man babies but we discover and
it's actually all a bigger organization
they are probably gonna be the big bads
going ahead and Nikki even writes down
the name just in case you missed it now
these tie in heavily with the hulks and
the potential DNA plot that we're
getting rpk said that the intelligent
show were the ones behind it all and
it's likely that we'll get the leader
popping up or at least tease to him Tim
black Nelson was brought on stage at d23
and it's been confirmed that he will be
appearing as the leader in the next
Captain America movie because of this I
think we will likely find out that he's
been working behind the scenes to try
and get she-hulk's DNA much like Jen he
ended up going into his own
transformation due to the Hulk's blood
and therefore it makes sense that he
tried to get more I don't know where
he's been for the last decade but I
think that he's probably behind this in
some form or another the leader being
the big bad for Captain America brings a
lot with it and due to his vast
intelligence he's likely hide out with
the villains to help create a new world
order in the comics he wasn't really
someone who fought hand-to-hand with
people but he did pull in other super
villains to help do the Dirty Work he
also created Red She-Hulk which would be
a great vote for Jen to face off against
in the future he may even tie in with a
potential Red Hulk plot though it is
difficult to guess how Marvel will
navigate this due to William hurt's
passing now back at the wedding Jen
donds her bridesmaid's dress which is
way too big for her showing how she
probably gave the machine for She-Hulk
she's got the best date that anyone
could help for and it could be worse
love it could be worse now we get a DJ
set by Chad who's called DJ incredible
he rocks a Hulk t-shirt and will also be
somewhat cousins with the Hulk cashing
in on the name whereas Jen doesn't want
to Jen gets mortal and it reminds me a
lot of Matt Smith's dancing at the
wedding in Doctor Who really Matt Smith
has done a lot of weird dancing scenes
and I've heard he's a Damon on the Dance
Floor okay and she later tries to ring
Bruce but can't get through and it's
been so long I totally forgot about the
Saka stuff bring him back yeah bring him
back next week and I promise I'll
forgive all the Daredevil stuff now we
see this settlement playing out and Mr
Immortal mentions baroness Cromwell
which could be another Lily Cromwell
from the comics this was a vampire
character known as baroness blood who
also had lots of ties to Dracula due to
the length of the marriages and children
involved it makes things very
complicated but Nikki sorts it all out
she gives the women what they want girls
get it done and Paul gets tone a new one
like I will when I lose my subscribers
in the divorce again feels like she
falls short of her alter ego but Josh
makes her feel amazing however it's
ruined by having to vomit as we know
when she's in her She-Hulk Persona she
can't get drunk this actually led to a
big scene in the comics Jen was getting
drunk at the bar when she was offered
the job by Holloway and he asked her to
turn back into her normal form so that
he could formally present it to her she
did but doing this made the alcohol hit
her system and she ended up crashing out
on the floor Titania starts a fight with
her and Jen stumbles when turning
initially reminding me a lot of Bruce
being unable to do it in Infinity War
she cracks the ground with her foot and
this is similar to iconography from the
dance slot run it's better than the
courtroom fight though it ends pretty
quickly when Titania face plants and
makes a public display of herself it
initially seems like Lulu will be angry
but he's just happy to have She-Hulk at
her wedding from here we then jump back
to Nikki and Mallory and see them
checking out the intelligent show
website now the intelligent your website
site has a couple of Easter eggs on it
and these are all really really
interesting really the QR code on the
security truck is missing making me
think they CGI did in and then forgot to
do it here in the top left we can see
the top 10 best travel destinations and
on the map we can see the City
Cookeville this is a location that shut
up and Logie and Sylvie actually bombed
this area in an alternative timeline
they end up pressing the [ __ ] She-Hulk
Tab and this leads to a member's only
login there is a Hulk King hashtag and
the character Hulk King is an emperor in
the comics which ties in with the crown
that we see him wearing I also feel like
this space is based on Pepe the Frog AKA
a famous meme on the internet this may
end up being the leader as the character
of course used a similar way to contact
people in The Incredible Hulk I wouldn't
be surprised if this is linked to him
with him also being a Hulk Nikki creates
an account and she uses all the typical
language that you'd see on a
misogynistic Forum shoot should call it
incella gentia in Saladin Shea crap joke
but we also get a split second flash of
her account which which has a couple of
digs that bro culture on it lots of talk
about Bitcoin crypto and protein and we
also see the mention of ALK hunting feel
like this might be a shot at Joe Rogan
but let me know below also yeah if you
like Joe Rogan I'm not having a go at
you yet I'm just pointing it out I
listened to his podcast of people I'm
interested in are on it and I'm not down
with this whole hating everyone because
they said something that you disagree
with once you're all welcome at the
Kevin spoiler show even you Ryan Arie
even you see that was nice now on this
reddit-esque site there's calls to
cancel She-Hulk shoot her and post
calling her dumb there's also a
collection of memes going over how she's
stupid how she wants equality but still
wants you to pay for dinner how she
wears yoga pants but gets mad when you
look and how she dresses like a man this
ladder is because she couldn't fit in
her suits and therefore had to buy men's
clothing in order to walk around the
office there's also one talking about
how Hulk would beat her in a fight which
I think is Marvel being like we all saw
what happened in episode one right
didn't we she hooked debate the Hulk now
Nikki ends up telling Jan against
Mallory's wishes which could end up
being something that she Taps into if
she ends up becoming a Villain at the
wedding we see the intelligentia are
spying on Jen and they discard the bent
needle in favor of a vibranium one
anyways
every time sheets available at
xeroedition.com
I thought it's a character that
constantly keeps popping up and after
last week's episode I have even more
questions about him he was of course
going to glkh but I don't know why he'd
be interested in a superhero Law Firm
unless he was only going there to get
closer to She-Hulk if you've been
checking out our breakdown so far then
you know how we've talked about how we
think he was the same guy in The
Wrecking Crew that tried to jab a needle
in her play this a couple of times but
just in case you missed it let's listen
to The Voice similarities impenetrable
skin yeah my skin is impenetrable at
least with anything on Earth even
vibranium when she turned into She-Hulk
I couldn't Pierce that nasty green skin
damn it I'm also gonna be mad here he is
of course talking about jabbing a needle
in her and he also tried to jab a needle
in her on the day day
now if you look at the features we can
see under the mask as well they also
look similar and the fact that he was
the only one who covered his face makes
me think that there is something going
on with this member that will lead to a
crazy big reveal I do feel like I'm
asking about the vibranium one being
able to pierce her skin is what leads
into this changer and The Wrecking Crew
May attack next week with him being
involved it's also possible that Josh
may be in on this too which is how they
know when to surveil her I think that
Todd at the very least is gonna be a
definite if we get it right and I don't
want to hear nothing about no failed
Theory time ever again and that's the
end
[Music]
are we good at the crates which has some
shots from the wedding including Jen's
cousin kissing Lulu you also have some
snaps of Jonathan and Josh and it's a
nice fun continuation of the event
Titania gets her veneers fixed up and we
see Nikki and Mallory recording a
conversation between Mr mortal and one
of his wives no post credit scene this
time and overall I thought this was an
okay episode but again sounding like a
broken record none of these feel like
they're home runs maybe my expectations
for this being a daredevil episode were
misled but I ended up being so high from
last week to then feeling slightly
disappointed upon realizing that wasn't
the case maybe that's on me but trying
to view this objectively I think that
it's an okay one that's teasing a bigger
picture which is more of what I want
from the show rather than it just all
being self-contained Titania is still a
chump though and she's not really posing
a threat to Jen at all so I don't really
think that she's that good of a villain
where that Jen has completely wiped the
floor with her every time that she's
popped it up and I'm actually hoping
that Titania to at least one went into
provide some Dynamics to the show
everybody just feels like it's going
through the motions because she
constantly loses I think that would at
least mix things up a bit so yeah let me
know what you think I think it's okay
but if you go in with the expectations
that it's gonna be Daredevil then you
might be disappointed so once more it's
another week where Kevin spoilers has
gone from being called a shelf but yes
and yes for every time I say something
is good to now being a hater at the
other end of the spectrum because I say
something's okay totally open to hearing
your thoughts though but I'm off to make
my intelligent your login you damn some
of the [ __ ] you should have brought
Madden
now we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of Thor 11
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now similar to you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our Brighton of handle
which will be linked on screen right now
go with the three episodes and a lot of
fun Jared did it he's the George
operates of the channel and he loved it
and uh yeah definitely go head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for singing through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace